hundreds of passengers on board a United
Airlines flight were left trapped on the
tarmac in Canada for more than 15 hours
flight 179 left Newark New Jersey headed
to Hong Kong on Saturday 250 passengers
and 15 crew were on board about three
hours into the flight the plane was
diverted to Newfoundland after a
passenger had a medical emergency the
passenger was taken to the hospital but
before the plane could take off one of
the emergency doors malfunctioned in the
freezing temperatures it happened to be
minus 25 with minus 65 degree windchill
so with no customs borders officers
working overnight passengers were forced
to spend the night on the plane the
plane had heat but only limited snacks
the choice of airport I think was very
poor
since you know Airport was not equipped
I think everybody understood that there
was a circumstance that said nobody
could really control second United
Airlines plane landed in Canada around
noon on Sunday and brought the stranded
passengers back to Newark they arrived
last night about 27 hours after their
original departure United has apologized
and offered the customers refunds
compensation and hotel accommodations
headache for them